[Music]  before I knew it it was time to head  back home  I hope we'll soon be able to begin  mending the long broken relationship  between our two countries despite the  differences in our governments at a  human level there's so much we share  laughter music the love of good food and  a sheer genius of rum in a box I've been  in Havana for four days it's been one of  the greatest experiences of my life  the people here are talented they're  funny they're vivacious they're warm I I  can't say enough good about the people  of Havana in Cuba and I can't wait to  come back they've all no tiempo my hour  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]